imagine if all cars behaved like this
instead of falling apart after a single
crash what if we all had cars that were
indestructible would there be fewer
fatalities caused by car accidents
what would indestructible cars be made
of and could this end up being a bad
thing this is what if and here's what
would happen if all cars were
indestructible every year nearly 1.25
million people died in car accidents
around the world that's an average of
3200 deaths every day in the United
States alone over 2 million people
become injured or disabled from car
accidents each year
it's no secret roads can be dangerous if
we are not careful so would an
indestructible car be able to solve our
safety issues first we need to decide
what our vehicles would be made of they
could all be cyber trucks these are made
out of a type of stainless steel alloy
which is the same material used in
spaceships but are they nuke proof
probably not
we would want our cars to be completely
indestructible meaning that if we were
to throw a nuke at one our car would be
the only thing left standing maybe we
could all drive around in u.s.
presidential limos which are essentially
drivable tanks that are completely
bulletproof the only issue with them is
they cost about 1 million dollars per
car instead we'd most likely take the
materials used in the cyber truck and
coat them with a substance known as
graphene this rare material is one of
the strongest known to man it's 200
times stronger than steel and although
it might not be nuke proof it would be
pretty close
okay now that we have our indestructible
vehicle what would this do for accidents
on the road well your car would be
completely fine and you'd be paying a
lot less in insurance but just because
your vehicle is indestructible doesn't
mean that you are sure fatalities and
injuries for passengers would certainly
be reduced
having indestructible vehicles means
your car won't explode and there will be
less flying debris everywhere but that
would stop you from being flung and
tossed around if you did happen to get
into an accident and what about the
people who aren't in vehicles with
indestructible cars roaming around
pedestrians would want to be much more
careful as getting hit by one of these
would certainly mean death SUVs are
already some of the deadliest cars for
pedestrians so having roads lined with
big trucks like this could have only
result in more pedestrian deaths on the
other hand injuries inside of
indestructible cars would be
significantly reduced so that's a good
thing what might not be so good is the
fact that these things last forever and
by forever I mean it literally we're not
talking 100 or 1000 years we mean until
the end of time no more car breakdowns
and spending thousands of dollars on
repairs this all sounds like a great
what-if but wait that's not all come on
you knew this was coming with
indestructible cars there's only one
thing we would need to think about how
would we get rid of these things you
might be thinking well why would we need
to do that but let's face it even if we
had cars that would never break we'd
still want to buy new ones you buy a new
phone or new clothes when you don't
really need them so wouldn't that also
apply to vehicles not only that but car
manufacturers would be enticing us to
find new cars every year as each
iteration would implement new features
that we didn't have previously so now
that we're buying new cars what
we do with our old ones right now in the
United States over 12 million cars are
recycled every year and we're lucky
enough that 86 percent of a car can be
recycled from the steel to the plastic
they're all melted down to be used for
new cars this is much better for the
environment as less water and pollutants
are used in comparison to making a new
car but since we can't recycle these old
indestructible cars and brand new cars
would still be made it would create much
more damage to the environment these old
cars would have to sit in a landfill
somewhere luckily you could save some of
them for new drivers but eventually so
many people would buy new cars that
there would be more cars than people in
certain parts of the world this number
would slowly increase says there's just
no way to get rid of these
indestructible cars if we kept on
manufacturing them they'd eventually
take over all the space we have on earth
and if this isn't bad enough we'd also
have tons of job loss even though we'd
still be making some new vehicles it
won't be anywhere near the 100 million
we're producing globally today meaning
much fewer jobs in the car industry so
having these indestructible cars might
sound useful but it would ultimately do
more harm than good a better approach
would be to power all our cars with
electricity instead of gas but we'll
leave that story for another what-if
you